THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING US
TONIGHT.
"AC 360" STARTS NOW.
>>> THE FORMER PRESIDENT'S CHIEF
OF STAFF SETTING DOCUMENTS ON
FIRE AND QANON BEING DISCUSSED
FAVORABLY AT THE HIGHEST LEVELS
OF THE WHITE HOUSE.
PAMELA BROWN HERE IN FOR
ANDERSON TONIGHT.
THOSE ARE JUST SOME OF THE
REVELATIONS FROM TESTIMONY
RELEASED TODAY BY THE JANUARY
6th COMMITTEE.
AND IN BOTH CASES, TESTIMONY BY
CASSIDY HUTCHINSON, FORMER CLOSE
AIDE TO THEN CHIEF OF STAFF MARK
MEADOWS.
JESSICA SCHNEIDER JOINS US WITH
THE VERY LATEST ON THIS STRIKING
NEWLY REVEALED TESTIMONY.
REALLY SOME STUNNING DETAILS
COMING OUT OF THESE TRANSCRIPTS,
JESSICA.
>> YEAH, PAMELA, WE'VE BEEN
SEEING THIS THROUGHOUT THE PAST
FEW DAYS.
THIS ONE IN PARTICULAR A LOT OF
NEW DETAILS.
THAT'S PARTICULARLY BECAUSE ONE
OF THESE IS CASSIDY HUTCHINSON'S
FINAL DEPOSITION.
IT DATES FROM JUNE 2022.
CRUCIALLY, THAT WAS RIGHT AFTER
CASSIDY HUTCHINSON HAD FIRED HER
TRUMP WORLD ATTORNEY, AND HER
NEW ATTORNEY WAS REALLY LETTING
HER CORRECT THE RECORD AND TELL
EVERY TRUTH FOR THE COMMITTEE.
SO FIRST THING SHE TOLD THE
COMMITTEE THAT SHE SAW MARK
MEADOWS BURNING DOCUMENTS IN HIS
OFFICE FIREPLACE, SHE SAYS ABOUT
A DOZEN TIMES.
AND THAT AMOUNTED IN HER
ESTIMATION TO ONCE OR TWICE A
WEEK.
THAT WAS BETWEEN DECEMBER 2020
AND JANUARY 2021.
SHE SAYS ALSO AT LEAST TWICE SHE
SAW MEADOWS BURNING DOCUMENTS
AFTER MEETINGS WITH REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSMAN SCOTT PERRY, WHO OF
COURSE WAS SUBPOENAED BY THE
COMMITTEE, BUT HE NEVER
COMPLIED.
THEN IN ADDITION, CASSIDY
HUTCHINSON TOLD THE COMMITTEE
HOW THESE DISCUSSIONS ABOUT
QANON CONSPIRACIES REALLY
PERMEATED THROUGHOUT THE WHITE
HOUSE AFTER THE ELECTION.
SHE SAID NOT ONLY DID MARK
MEADOWS BRING IT UP, BUT
CONGRESSWOMAN MARJORIE TAYLOR
GREENE.
SHE MADE MENTION OF WHAT IS THIS
FAR RIGHT WING POLITICAL
MOVEMENT THAT SPREADS THESE
OUTLANDISH CONSPIRACY THEORIES.
AND THEN CASSIDY HUTCHINSON SAID
SHE HAD THIS EXCHANGE WITH WHITE
HOUSE TRADE ADVISER PETER
NAVARRO.
CASSIDY HUTCHINSON SAYING "AT
ONE POINT I HAD SARCASTICALLY
SAID OH, IS THIS FROM YOUR QANON
FRIENDS, PETER?
BECAUSE HE WOULD TALK TO ME
FREQUENTLY ABOUT HIS QANON
FRIENDS.
HE SAID HAVE YOU LOOKED INTO IT
CASS?
THEY POINT OUT A LOT OF GOOD
IDEAS.
YOU REALLY NEED TO READ.
THIS MAKE SURE THE CHIEF SEES
THIS.
CASSIDY HUTCHINSON SAID I DID
NOTE TAKE THIS AS SARCASM.
PETER NAVARRO HAS BEEN INDICTED
FOR NOT COMPLYING WITH THE
CITY'S SUBPOENAS.
BUT AS THESE TRANSCRIPTS TRICKLE
OUT HERE, AS WE'RE EXPECTING
THROUGHOUT THE WEEK, THERE ARE A
LOT OF CRUCIAL NEW DETAILS IN
HERE THAT WE MIGHT NOT HAVE SEEN
BEFORE.
>> YEAH.
AND IT'S JUST REMARKABLE THAT A
TOP ADMINISTRATION OFFICIAL LIKE
PETER NAVARRO WOULD BE GIVING
CREDENCE TO QANON AND THESE
RIDICULOUS CONSPIRACY THEORIES.
WE'RE ALSO LEARNING MORE ABOUT
WHAT FORMER WHITE HOUSE PRESS
SECRETARY JUDGE DEAR TOLD THE
COMMITTEE.
WHAT DO YOU KNOW?
>> JUDD DEAR TOLD THE COMMITTEE
HE REALLY HEARD THIS ALL GOSSIP.
BUT STILL, IT WAS THE WEEK AFTER
THE 2020 ELECTION.
HE HEARD FROM THEM THAT TRUMP IN
FACT WAS CONSIDERING CONCEDING,
AND EVEN INVITING THE BIDENS TO
THE WHITE HOUSE.
SO JUDD DEER SAID HE WAS LOOPED
IN ON THE CONVERSATIONS BECAUSE
HE WOULD HAVE BEEN THE ONE
ARRANGING THE PRESS ACCESS FOR
ANY VISIT FROM THE BIDENS.
DEER TOLD THE COMMITTEE THIS.
HE SAID IN THE WEEK AFTER THE
ELECTION, THERE WAS GOSSIP
AROUND THE BUILDING THAT HE WAS
SERIOUSLY CONSIDERING CONCEDING,
EVEN STRONGLY CONSIDERING
INVITING THE PRESIDENT-ELECT AND
THE INCOMING FIRST LADY TO THE
WHITE HOUSE.
OF COURSE, THOUGH, NONE OF THOSE
THINGS HAPPENED.
TRUMP REFUSED TO CONCEDE.
HE HELD ON TO THOSE CLAIMS OF A
STOLEN ELECTION, AND NONE OF
THOSE RUMORS ACTUALLY CAME TO
FRUITION.
>> THEY DIDN'T.
I KNOW FROM MY REPORTING A THE
TIME THAT WHITE HOUSE OFFICIALS,
THEY WERE SAYING THAT TO
REPORTERS THAT THAT'S WHAT THEY
WERE HEARING.
JESSICA SCHNEIDER, STAY WITH US.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I WANT TO BRING IN CNN CHIEF
POLITICAL ANALYST GLORIA BORGER
ALONG WITH FORMER PROSECUTOR
GLORIA ROGERS.
IS THERE ANY PARALLEL IN U.S.
HISTORY THAT YOU'RE AWARE OF FOR
A WHITE HOUSE CHIEF OF STAFF TO
BE BURNING DOCUMENTS IN A
FIREPLACE INSIDE THE WHITE
HOUSE?
>> YOU KNOW, OFF THE TOP OF MY
HEAD, I CANNOT THINK OF ANY.
EVEN RICHARD NIXON DIDN'T BURN
THE TAPES.
THERE WAS A GAP, BUT HE DIDN'T
BURN THE TAPES.
THIS IS STUNNING.
AND LOOK AT THE TIMING OF THIS.
AFTER THE ELECTION, BEFORE
JANUARY 6th.
I THINK WE SHOULD POINT OUT THAT
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THOSE
DOCUMENTS WERE.
WE DON'T KNOW WHETHER THEY WERE
REQUIRED BY THE ARCHIVES BECAUSE
OF THE PRESIDENTIAL RECORDS ACT
TO BE PRESERVED.
BUT I WOULD SAY UNLESS THIS WAS
SOME KIND OF A SHOPPING LIST
THAT HE WAS THROWING INSIDE THE
FIREPLACE FOR THESE DOZEN TIMES,
THAT THIS IS A REAL PROBLEM FOR
MARK MEADOWS.
WHAT WAS HE THINKING ABOUT WHEN
HE THREW THINGS IN THE FIREPLACE
THAT HE THOUGHT NEEDED TO BE
DESTROYED?
>> WELL, AND WE KNOW ACCORDING
TO THE TESTIMONY FROM CASSIDY
HUTCHINSON, TWO OF THE TIMES
WHERE AFTER MEETING WITH
CONGRESSMAN SCOTT PERRY WHO
TRIED TO INSTALL JEFFREY CLARK
AS HEAD OF DOJ, AS THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL WHO TRIED TO GET DNI TO
INVESTIGATE SOME OF THESE
CONSPIRACY THEORIES AND DEFIED
THE SUBPOENA FROM THE COMMITTEE.
IS THERE ANY LEGAL JUSTIFICATION
THAT YOU KNOW OF THAT WOULD
PERMIT A LEGAL WHITE HOUSE STAFF
TO BURN DOCUMENTS LIKE THIS?
>> WELL, AS GLORIA SAID, PAMELA,
ONLY IF IT WAS SOMETHING THAT
REALLY HAS NOTHING AT ALL TO DO
WITH THE JOB.
AND ALMOST EVERYTHING HAS TO BE
MAINTAINED PURSUANT TO THE
PRESIDENTIAL RECORDS ACT.
IT'S LIKELY THAT WHATEVER WAS
BEING BURNED WAS BEING BURNED IN
VIOLATION OF THE ACT.
THE PROBLEM IS IF YOU'RE
THINKING ABOUT CRIMINAL LAW, OF
COURSE, YOU KNOW, IT'S NOT GOOD
ENOUGH TO SAY IT PROBABLY WAS.
YOU WOULD NEED PROOF BEYOND A
REASONABLE DOUBT.
IT JUST GIVES PROSECUTORS
ANOTHER REASON TO DIG INTO MARK
MEADOWS AS POTENTIALLY EITHER A
CRIMINAL DEFENDANT OR THEIR
CRUCIAL INSIDER WITNESS IN THEIR
INVESTIGATION.
>> YEAH, LET'S TALK A LITTLE BIT
MORE ABOUT THAT.
WE KNOW THAT CASSIDY HUTCHINSON
IS ALREADY COOPERATING WITH THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
HOW DO YOU THINK THIS FITS INTO
THEIR INVESTIGATION?
AND DOES IT GIVE THEM LEVERAGE
AGAINST MEADOWS?
>> WELL, THEY'VE LONG HAD A LOT
OF LEVERAGE AGAINST MARK
MEADOWS.
HE HAS BEEN CENTRAL TO ALL OF
THE DIFFERENT STRANDS OF THE
PLOT THAT THEY'VE BEEN PURSUING
FOR SOME TIME.
THIS IS JUST ADDED TO THE PILE
OF EVIDENCE THAT THEY WANT TO
CONFRONT MARK MEADOWS ABOUT.
THEY'LL CERTAINLY BE LOOKING AT
MEADOWS.
THE QUESTION IS, IS HE ALREADY
TALKING TO THEM?
ARE THEY TREATING HIM AS A
POTENTIAL DEFENDANT?
ARE THEY GOING TO APPROACH HIM
AS A COOPERATING WITNESS?
THAT WILL BE FOR DOJ TO DECIDE.
BUT THEY HAVE ALL OF THOSE
OPTIONS ON THE TABLE BECAUSE
THERE IS SO MUCH EVIDENCE THAT
MARK MEADOWS WAS AT THE CENTER
OF THIS CONSPIRACY AND KNEW ALL
ABOUT ITS VARIOUS PARTS.
>> GLORIA, WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF
THE FACT THAT FORMER TRUMP AIDE
PETER NAVARRO, AS WELL AS
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSWOMAN
MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE WERE
PUSHING QANON CONSPIRACY
THEORIES INSIDE THE WHITE HOUSE?
>> IT'S BIZARRE.
IT'S OUTRAGEOUS.
AND I NEVER THOUGHT I'D SAY
WHITE HOUSE AND QANON IN THE
SAME SENTENCE.
AND IT IS REMARKABLE TO ME THAT
THIS EVEN WENT AS HIGH AS THE
PRESIDENT, THE FORMER PRESIDENT
HIMSELF.
I MEAN, CASSIDY HUTCHINSON TALKS
ABOUT MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE
BEING AT A TRUMP RALLY IN
GEORGIA BEFORE JANUARY 6th, AND
THIS IS A QUOTE FROM CASSIDY
HUTCHINSON.
SHE WAS SHOWING HIM PICTURES OF
THEM, MEANING QANON, TRAVELING
TO WASHINGTON, D.C. FOR THE
RALLY ON THE 6th.
WHAT DID THE FORMER PRESIDENT
SAY ABOUT THAT?
OH, THAT'S GREAT?
SO EXCITED TO SEE QANON AT MY
RALLY?
I MEAN, WHAT WAS THAT ABOUT?
>> YEAH.
>> AND I REMEMBER COVERING THE
WHITE HOUSE, THE PRESIDENT WAS
ASKED MULTIPLE TIMES ABOUT
QANON.
AND HE WAS ALWAYS RELUCTANT TO
BASH THEM.
>> EXACTLY.
>> OR CRITICIZE THEM.
SO THIS JUST KIND OF ADDS AN
INTERESTING LAYER TO THAT.
JESSICA, CASSIDY HUTCHINSON ALSO
TESTIFIED TO THE COMMITTEE ABOUT
HOW MARK MEADOWS WAS MANAGING
OVAL OFFICE MEETINGS DURING THE
TRANSITION PERIOD.
WHAT DID SHE TELL THEM?
>> SO WE'RE TALKING ABOUT MARK
MEADOWS.
SHE SAW HIM BURNING DOCUMENTS.
BUT IT ALSO TURNS OUT HE WAS
GIVING THIS DIRECT ALTERNATIVE
SOME OF THE WHITE HOUSE STAFF
DURING THE TRANSITION PERIOD TO
KEEP WHAT HE CALLED A CLOSE HOLD
ON ANY OF THEIR MEETINGS, AND HE
BASICALLY SAID DON'T WORRY ABOUT
WHAT EXACTLY THAT MEANS.
I'LL EXPLAIN IT LATER.
BUT DON'T GIVE ANY OF THIS
INFORMATION OUT.
DON'T LEAK IT.
DON'T TELL ANYBODY.
AND ON TOP OF THAT, CASSIDY
HUTCHINSON SAYS THAT THAT MEANS
THAT NONE OF THESE MEETINGS WERE
RECORDED IN THE OVAL OFFICE
DIARIES.
SO THERE IS NO RECORD OF THEM.
>> YEAH.
>> SHE SAYS THAT SHE DOESN'T
REALLY REMEMBER WHAT WAS
DISCUSSED AT THESE MEETINGS, IF
ANYTHING SURROUNDING JANUARY 6th
WAS DISCUSSED, BUT IT REALLY
ADDS THIS OTHER LAYER TO MARK
MEADOWS' POTENTIALLY BURNING
DOCUMENTS, NOW MAKING A
CONCERTED EFFORT NOT TO CREATE
ANY DOCUMENTS THAT WERE SUPPOSED
TO BE CREATED AS A RECORD OF
WHAT WAS GOING ON AT THE WHITE
HOUSE.
SO THAT'S ANOTHER CONCERNING
ELEMENT TO THIS.
>> YEAH, AND GLORIA, WHAT
CASSIDY HUTCHINSON SAID ABOUT
THIS WAS CORROBORATED.
>> SURE.
>> BY WHAT SOURCES TOLD CNN THAT
THE WHITE HOUSE DIARIST TOLD THE
COMMITTEE EARLIER IN THE YEAR
THAT SIGNIFICANTLY LESS
INFORMATION ABOUT TRUMP'S CALLS
AND VISITS WERE BEING PROVIDED
IN THE DAYS LEADING UP TO
JANUARY 6th.
PUTTING ALL THE PIECES TOGETHER
AND KNOWING WHAT WAS HAPPENING
IN THE MONTHS AFTER THE
ELECTION, IT BEGS THE QUESTION
OF WHAT MEADOWS WAS TRYING TO
KEEP CLOSE HOLD.
>> AND WHO WAS HE TRYING TO
PROTECT.
THIS IS THE QUESTION.
IF THE PRESIDENT, THE FORMER
PRESIDENT'S BEHAVIOR GREW MORE
AND MORE BIZARRE, IF THERE WERE
DISCUSSIONS GOING ON INSIDE THE
OVAL OFFICE ABOUT JANUARY 6th,
FOR EXAMPLE, OR ABOUT CHANGES AT
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT, ET
CETERA, ET CETERA, WHICH WE'VE
REPORTED, THESE ARE IMPORTANT
CONVERSATIONS THAT NEED TO BE
ARCHIVED.
AND WHAT MARK MEADOWS WAS SAYING
WAS SHH, DON'T TELL THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ABOUT THIS.
DON'T LET THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
KNOW WHAT WAS GOING ON IN TH